أستمتع عندما ألعب كرة القدم ، أحاول
احترام جميع زملائي في الفريق ، واحترام
المنافسين ، واحترام المشجعين ووسائل الإعلام
أيضًا ، وسأحاول القيام
بعملي بأفضل طريقة أحب كرة القدم ، ولا
أعرف أنني أعتقد أن الناس هم من يفعلون ذلك.  يمكنني أن أقرر
معرفة متى يكون موقعي في
النادي أو في التاريخ في الدوري الإسباني ، لكن
بالنسبة لي ، ليس هذا هو الأهم هو
أن أعيش كل يوم ،
وأحب الأشياء البسيطة التي أحبها عندما
لعبت عندما سجلت نتائجك الطبية  كنت
معتادًا على تقبيل خاتم زواجك ، فأنت
رجل فخور جدًا بالعائلة ، نعم ، ما هو
الاحتفال الأكثر غرابة الذي
رأيته يفعله لاعبون آخرون ، نعم ، إنهم
احتفال مجنون لا أعلم أعتقد
أحيانًا أنني أحب كل الأوقات  لا
يعجبني أعتقد أن
الاحتفال البسيط بالنسبة لي هو أفضل
كورا دواين.
لحظات هناك بالنسبة لي عائلتي زوجتي
نصنعها مذهل  عائلة مكونة من
خمسة أطفال وبالطبع والديّ
أخي أختي جميع أفراد العائلة
ولكن بالنسبة لي فإن ركيزتي في حياتي
هي زوجتي الآن ، فنحن نخلق
عائلة رائعة وأيضًا عندما أحصل على 1-1 أسجل
من الواضح أن الأهداف كانت لها من قبل
، وبالنسبة لأطفالي ،
لم تمنحك كرة القدم حياة رائعة ، ماذا كنت
تعتقد أنك كنت ستحصل عليه لو لم تكن
تلعب كرة
القدم ، وإذا كنت عندما كنت
طفلاً كنت دائمًا صغيراً  كان لدي ابنة أعتقد أنني إذا كنت
أرغب في اللعب مرة أخرى وإلا
كنت سأعالج ابنة مثل
رأسين إلى أنيماس لا أعرف ما
يقولونه باللغة الإنجليزية أن الطبيب
البيطري البيطري كان طريقًا آخر لي
ولكن لحسن الحظ كنت كذلك  لاعب كرة قدم
يمكنني الاستمتاع بحلمي الآن ، أعتقد أنك
كنت طبيبًا بيطريًا جيدًا للغاية ، لكن من
الواضح أنك إذا كنت
لا تزال في الوطن في إسبانيا ، فسيتم
التعرف عليك طوال الوقت كم مرة يتم
التعرف عليك في نيويورك  لا هنا
مثالي إنه مثل الجنة بالنسبة
لي  يمكنني ركوب مترو الأنفاق كل يوم
للوصول إلى المكتب يمكنني العمل
مع أطفالي بالطبع
هناك أيضًا الكثير من القصص هناك الكثير من
الناس يحبون كرة القدم هنا في
نيويورك وأحيانًا يتعرفون
علي ولكن يمكنني ذلك  ترك الكورال ليس كما هو الحال في
إسبانيا لا ولكن في إسبانيا في مدينتي ، مدريد
هي مدينتي ، ولا أقول
دائمًا أنني أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة جدًا عندما أعود
إلى هذا الألم عندما لعبت ، كنت
ترتدي الرقم سبعة في معظم مسيرتك المهنية
و  التي أصبحت حقًا جزءًا من هويتك
، أتساءل ما هو هذا الرقم الذي
يعنيه الرقم سبعة بالنسبة لك الآن عندما ترى
الرقم سبعة ، ما رأيك
في علاج الرقم سبعة
مثل رمز لا ، فهم يلعبون أسماء كبيرة
في تاريخ النادي الآن
برقم سبعة لا يمكن لأميليا أن تتخبط عليك
أمانسيو خوانيتو هل هذا الرقم يشبه
شيئًا رمزيًا للنادي لا
كل الرقم مهم
المهم الرقم يعرف أنك تعرف
أنه لا يوجد مدريد ولكن  لكن على وجه الخصوص
أنا  رقم سبعة في هذا النادي هو
شيء خاص ولكن أعتقد أنه
ليس الأهم ولكن بالنسبة لي كان
شرفًا كبيرًا أن آخذ هذا ESA خلال موسم 17 أو